isa tohama fled her village because she
feared attacks by armed groups
her eight-month-old daughter became
severely malnourished weeks later
homeless and hungry isoto couldn't
produce enough breast milk
so she traveled several hours to reach a
hospital in the town of dory
since being displaced we haven't
received support we used to have food to
eat when we were in our home but we
don't think we can return i'm really
afraid my children will
starve she's among hundreds of thousands
the u.n says are on the brink of
starvation in burkina faso
their hungers fueled by violence linked
to years of unrest in the largely
lawless sahel region that's forced many
from their homes almost 60 percent of
all health centers in the sahel have
been forced to close
many of the people here have come from
villages where there's no longer any
functioning health facilities by the
time they arrive doctors say the
children are often extremely
malnourished many like these babies here
need oxygen to survive
doctors say the most severe cases die
within 24 hours after arrival and health
workers are preparing for the situation
to get worse as security problems
increase
mutinous soldiers ousted the president
in january
since then attacks by armed groups have
increased and spread
the situation is escalating every day
and if the government can find the right
strategy in six months there will be
humanitarian disaster
nearly two million people are internally
displaced
most fleeing rural areas for cities
which are already short of key supplies
we don't have water we don't have
anything i suffer a lot
i really need any kind of support
because i'm suffering
aid workers are struggling to cope with
the rising needs and shrinking funds
we still need more than 18 million
dollars to fill the gap of financial
resources in order to take care of these
children
and he warns if the money doesn't arrive
the crisis will become even worse
sam mednick al jazeera dory burkina faso